okay so you sit down with Dean you say
wow this is a nice guy wow he's actually
going to Champion some things that I
feel very very strongly about but you're
a professional and so you say okay how
the heck is this guy going to win and uh
this conversation is going to be
released to the public on February 5th
um so South Carolina will have voted uh
both of us would be stunned if that was
somehow some like crazy
Dean very stunned Dean showing um but
we'll rerecord happens yeah yeah sure
I'd be very happy to it be my pleasure
um but both of us think that the major
opportunity is in Michigan in febru on
February 27th and we think it's kind of
a huge opportunity yes no it is
definitely a huge opportunity and uh
people will remember that Bernie won
Michigan in
2006 uh 16 I mean 2016 sorry I got I
lost 10 years there somewhere uh in 2016
and a surprise upset you know Michigan
is
a sort of microcosm of America you know
uh everybody thinks about it as just
bluecollar Auto industry which it is
obviously uh and they think of Detroit
um you know as a it's really the only
city there uh uh interestingly uh there
are more African-Americans in Michigan
than there are in South Carolina even
though we think of South Carolina as the
African-American um primary uh but
there're also small cities there are
rural areas uh and in 2016 you know
Bernie traveled all of them and I think
Dean will do this same thing uh Folks up
there really respond to the kind of they
haven't had a lot of retail politics so
if you are somebody who can practice
retail politics well as Dean Ken as we
saw in New Hampshire uh I think he's
going to do really well there he's gonna
he's gonna spark a lot of interest with
folks it is an Open Primary uh any they
don't have party registration in
Michigan so literally anybody who's
registered to vote can come out and vote
for Dean uh which creates a much bigger
pool of Voters you know New Hampshire uh
typically has a lot of independent
voters which it did this time but but
they all flocked into the Republican
primary to vote for Nikki Haley there
was a very well-funded effort on the
part of Nikki Haley to get those
Independents into the Republican primary
so you know it disadvantaged Dean in uh
uh New Hampshire uh but in Michigan I
think you're going to see a lot of
Independence and perhaps even some you
know former Christie voters or folks
like that who might uh come over and
vote for Dean in the Democratic primary
yeah so by the Numbers the New Hampshire
Republican primary Drew $315,000 voters
and the Democratic primary such as it
was Drew 110,000 so if you can imagine
let's call it 100,000 of those
Independence uh voting in the dean
versus Biden primary I bet Dean would
have gotten most of those votes and then
you can see him getting uh 40 45 even
winning that thing um but if you were in
New Hampshire as we were all you got
bombarded by was Nikki Hanley versus
Trump ads and so you'd think well that's
where the action is and so that's where
all the Independents voted now now in
Michigan February 27 the odds are very
very high that Dean versus Biden is the
only game in town yes because the
Republican South Carolina primary is on
February 24th and Nikki Haley will
almost assuredly lose very significantly
so there's a chance that she drops off
out before Feb 24 there's a very high
chance that she drops out on February 24
and then Dean might have the field all
to himself in the primary against Joe
Biden in a state that Joe Biden is
struggling in a poll came out recently
that had Joe Biden losing to Trump by
eight points in the general by the way
this is a state he won in 2020 so that's
that's a big sign and then if you
replaced Joe Biden with Gretchen Whitmer
the governor of Michigan all of a sudden
Whitmer beats Trump by four so that's a
12-point swing uh I agree with you that
Dean is a very good fit for the state
being from Minnesota I I said he plays
hockey and he's going to feel familiar I
mean Minnesota doesn't quite touch
Michigan it's a couple States over so
he's going to feel
familiar he'll do well in the upper
peninsula if he gets to the Upper
Peninsula he'll do well Joe Biden's
particularly vulnerable and this is
going to be an interesting bridge
building exercise for Dean but the Arab
American Community has completely turned
their back on Joe Biden in Michigan uh
it's a traditionally Democratic
constituency and they they're
essentially saying look none of us is
gonna vote for Joe um some of them are
flirting with Cornell West but some of
them want to find a more productive way
to channel their energies and if Dean
can make that case to that population
that would be an enormous in Road no it
absolutely would and you know Bernie did
that in 2016 Arab American community in
uh uh Michigan was critical to his
victory there and it was one of the few
communities where we had the support of
the local uh business Community the
local religious leaders the local
journalism folks uh it was sort of like
what Hillary had everywhere else uh and
I you know I think Dean has the
potential to build that kind of
Coalition uh in Michigan you're right
that the the community is very very
upset with Joe Biden and the way he's
handled the War uh and uh you know Joe
Biden has already canceled some visits
there uh because there was fear that you
know he would be either poorly received
or no one would show up at all so
there's a good opportunity to make
inroads there I mean and you're right
about the importance of this look the
entire rationale of Joe Biden's run is
that he was able to reassemble the blue
wall which was destroyed by Trump in
2016 that 2020 Joe Biden can put it
together now you and I have seen these
polls in these Battleground States
it's not just Michigan obviously
Wisconsin uh and others and you know
Pennsylvania if if Joe Biden if we we
demonstrate how weak he really is uh in
this state and other states in the blue
wall the entire rationale for his
campaign evaporates you know then it is
as he himself has says there are 50
Democrats who could beat Donald Trump uh
and probably there are 50 Democrats who
can do that but you know Dean Phillips
is the only one who has had the guts to
actually step up and try to do it well
I'm pumped to be be building the dean
machine with you um I think that we have
a chance to change the direction of
American politics on February 27th in
Michigan uh so if you'd like to have a
better uh sense of who's in in office go
meet Dean Phillips in Michigan he'll be
coming to a town near you tell your
friends if you're not in Michigan uh
send Dean's campaign a couple of bucks
if you can spare them but it's all going
to come down to what happens on Feb 27 I
think it's a golden opportunity we have
to make it happen though and Jee I'm
grateful to you for putting yourself
back into the ring to help Dean and Zach
and the team make it happen yeah well
I'm pleased I'm pleased to be here and
uh you know I was actually very proud of
what we did in New Hampshire we held the
president
under we held the president under 65% uh
there were about 10,000 votes for it
looks like for ceasefire um which you
know took votes from us and Nikki Haley
taking all the independ P so I you know
I'm I'm I feel very very good about what
happened in New Hampshire I think a lot
of people were actually surprised uh by
the performance you know South Carolina
was always going to be tough the
president's very popular there has
longtime personal ties in South Carolina
uh you know he has ties with Jim kurn
who is the sort of political Godfather
of South Carolina um so that was always
very going to be a very tough uh
political environment for us but you
know Michigan is a totally different
story and uh I think we're going to
really surprise folks there but we need
your help
yes let's go de24 Michigan
bb27 hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you